here's the big news Trump is declared a
national emergency which which most of
you probably know but hopefully you all
know this honestly I know it means very
little to the average person it means
almost everything yeah like you know
it's gonna allow the government to get
more funding more quickly there's
apparently is a program where this
allows states to have their emergency
services supplemented by federal funds
okay for the rest of us we're not gonna
see anything yeah your markets are gonna
be rated there's a comedic toilet paper
you're gonna hang out at home you're
gonna watch TV netflix catch up on I
don't know what you watching Westworld
or something I don't watch that anymore
I'm in the middle of the expanse right
now it's good that's good but here's
where it's funny all right let's have
some fun oh let's have some fun Mexico
is considering closing its border to
stop Americans bringing coronavirus into
its country as US case count passes mm
oh man I mean do they have cases now oh
six they do confirm cases no response
yeah it reminds me of you see the day
after tomorrow I yeah I think so when
when it's like the climate change
destroys the planet is that where it
freezes over or the big wave at all of
it all the wave comes first and then it
freezes and then it freezes I think I've
seen that and then the guys like he
draws that like my Dennis Quaid yeah
okay yeah he draws the line in the map
and he's like everyone's south of this
line must evacuate to Mexico or
something yeah and they're like are you
nuts and like what about everyone above
that it's too late for them it's too
late you just stay inside but then
there's like there's like a fake news
report where they're like the Mexican
government has agreed to allow illegal
immigrants from America to enter Mexico
in exchange for forgiving all Mexican
debt or something like that but this is
funny now the corona virus it becomes a
big deal Mexico wants to close its
borders with us
I'll have the tables the tables have
turned well Trump did say that Mexico is
gonna build the wall and Trump and Trump
warned us about China
last September he issued an order for
firms to leave China come back to the US
and a week later us like defense
specialists and advisers were saying
that China manufacturing our medicine
was a huge strategic vulnerability for
us totally
so I guess since 2004 Trump predicted a
long time 16 years they've been making
our medicine what if what so Mexico is
not gonna build a wall he said we're
gonna bet they're gonna pay for it what
if now what if now a bunch of like
American start rushing to the border and
then they're like no no no no no no no
stop and so they pay us to have our
border guide stop Americans for going
the other way oh you're laughing but in
six months when we're at 150 million
people infected and it's actually
happened and you're gonna be shaken yeah
well eaten grass no I do think it's
funny though because it's it's kind of I
don't know if it's ironic you know all
these people claimed that like it's it's
okay it's gonna be really funny when the
US is or if it does get inundated with
like infections yeah and then these
these like you know super lefty open
borders people I guess there's also you
know Liberty and open borders people -
they're gonna be like we're gonna go to
Mexico and where it's safe and their
guards are gonna be like nope when
they're black but but but we were gonna
let you guys in like we don't care we
want open borders man yeah we don't care
no but it's funny too because it's
almost like nations like their borders
yeah want to use them I want to be a
reason for this exact thing stopping the
spread of a pandemic yeah the funny
thing is I get it I get it
III tweeted if this really gets bad
people are gonna be damn happy that
Trump built that wall yeah and secured
our borders I mean it he didn't build
the whole strip right no no but hew all
of these people oh man there was a guy
who was a professor University okay any
quote tweeted me and he was like when
you're so stupid you think a wall can
stop a virus and I'm like oh my god dude
you're so stupid that you don't realize
people are carrying the virus and they
can't get through the wall right does he
does he think the virus is like floats
around like a ghost
yes embodies spirit traveling hundreds
of thousands of miles on the globe
definitely these people are merely as
dude right that's how it gets around
doesn't it so apparently there was there
was a story though where u.s. Border
Patrol turned away like you know
thousands of people who had come from
countries that now have infections okay
and so you know the point is being made
that border security is a good thing and
it is yeah how could you enforce a
quarantine with no borders yeah exactly
like we are we are enacting border
controls inside our own country already
yeah like New Rochelle New York is a
containment zone now whatever that means
containment quote I'm doing air quotes
but New York is New York is lit up so so
here's the story out of New York I'm
scared for my friends in New York I have
a lot of friends in New York and it's a
it's let's let slack tight let's let's
let's read this Mexico story too so I
want to make sure people you know they
want they want to know what's going on
with Mexico why isn't wise Mexico wanna
shut down our borders didn't mail the
Daily Mail reports for once the
conversation over closing the us-mexico
border is being driven by Mexico being
driven be Mexican by German by Maxine
health officials who say they are
considering shutting out Americans to
keep coronavirus out of their country
this is literally well it's one of the
more eagle but hold on hold that makes
sense but it's direct fun do you
remember the migrant caravan thing that
happened
yeah all the way up from South America
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're like big
thousands of people one of the arguments
was that they were bringing diseases and
all this these like probe and borders
median and in the United States were
like there is a smear and a conspiracy
theory do you know and and there were
there people tuberculosis yeah there are
people with the fluence that are not
vaccinated you know trying to come up
we're concerned about it yeah it makes
sense now Mexico is saying the exact
same thing well and big guys yeah I'd
stop in people on the other side of
their board or - right well eventually
Mexico border eventually they did
because Trump was like if you don't stop
them yeah then we're cutting you off and
I given you money right and they're like
whoa we'll stop I like money so they say
there are currently more than 2000 cases
while more than 2000 already in the US
and it's spreading rapidly 43 people
have died from it by contrast in Mexico
there have only been 16 confirmed cases
and no deaths yeah but let me we're not
testing enough you think they are I
don't think they are they forgot it
worse yeah we're like in Ohio which
supposedly had a hundred thousand cases
actually said that yeah the governor
came out and said that on the news this
month it was the governor I thought it
was now it was a high OH official okay
this woman what's what's her name the
director of Ohio's Department of
health said Friday her statement the
previous day that a hundred thousand
people in the state have coronavirus was
based on guesstimating guesstimating
casting doubt on the high number I like
how that's in quotes I was like no
that's not exactly what use to me this
was so so let's come back to us except I
got you again so here's what they say at
a press conference on Friday Health
Minister Hugo Lopez Cattell said Mexico
wouldn't bring the virus to the United
States rather the United States would
bring it here the possible flow of
coronavirus would come from the north to
the south if it were technically
necessary we would consider mechanisms
or of restriction or stronger
surveillance he said and these two bunch
of pictures Trump has said little on the
subject of coronavirus in Mexico unlike
several Latin American countries Mexico
has yet to take measures such as closing
schools or banning entry to people
coming from places with high numbers of
chronic virus cases however the private
tecnológico de Monterrey University said
on Thursday it would suspend academic
academic and click academic and classes
from next week until further notice
while Mexico's National Autonomous
University said it would tighten
preventative measures to prevent the
spread of the virus so I know that
that's about the gist of the story but
let's go back to this Ohio thing because
it's so this lady yeah man she said the
day before uh that there were a hundred
thousand people in Mexico I'm in Ohio
you know hi oh you see I'm talking about
Mexico yeah it's okay you know in Ohio
that had it yeah and I came down you're
like dude like this I have a friend in
Chicago who thinks he might have have
the virus and I'm like man that sucks
he's like yeah and I'm I'm in Chicago
and Ohio has a hundred thousand cases
I'm like exploit where are you where are
you getting that info and he's like the
governor said it and like sent me over
to Fox News and Fox News has a thing
like yep Ohio so this is a hundred
thousand cases unlike Fox News the same
as what yeah dr. Amy Acton yesterday at
a news conference so she was wrong it
was very wrong here's the thing that or
was she or was she listen listen listen
this is important if what she was saying
was true or if even that number is close
yeah that means the mortality rate is
substantially substantially lower
through then we think it is mm-hmm
what of it so in South Korea where
they're doing rigorous testing
Oh point six so it's still six times
higher than the flu I think still a good
reason that you know to enact some
security measures but if she was if she
was being honest that it was that it was
100k people and in her estimate that
being the mortality rate is like point
zero zero four percent well here
listener she says we know now just from
the fact of community spread says that
at least one percent or at the very
least 1% of our population is carrying
the virus in Ohio today we have eleven
point seven million people so the math
is over a hundred thousand so that's
where she wasn't actually guesstimating
she was using the the math she got that
one percent is infected so that just
gives you a sense of how the virus
spreads and is spreading quickly yeah
well she said a hundred thousand people
and I'm sure people freaked out because
of it I'm yeah man my buddy was
definitely freaking out so right so so
this is what's crazy they're postponing
the Louisiana primary already or is
already but they're yeah they're
postponing it that's an interesting
window into the future because I mean if
it gets worse if this just keeps getting
worse and worse directive 51 baby what's
gonna happen you're just gonna be like
look I'm just gonna be present for four
more years sorry guys not four more
years directive 51 just means
indefinitely or what it's a new vehicle
he literally can dissolve the government
create a new government that is National
Security presidential directive 51 it is
not a conspiracy theory it literally
exists it was created by George W Bush
and it states that in its its broad man
yeah there's an area so here's what's
crazy
it says if there's a massive loss of
life anywhere anywhere market collapse
even he has the power to dissolved US
government and create a new single
branch constitutional government that's
not America no that's
here's the thing though you've played
the division right yeah of course I know
you have we play it those of you
watching you've played the division
right that game is based off of this
that when everything falls apart and
there's nothing left this is what grants
the authority to say I'm in charge
here's what we're doing
follow orders or else now division two
funny enough spoiler alert if you are
still playing division doing I haven't
beaten it yet
the President did it he did yeah wait
what the president
in part to vision - yeah really did I
know that or is that did you not like a
game nope I didn't you didn't get to
that part
no the president did it yeah he's the I
did why he wanted all the power with the
Dragon 51 Wow yeah so what you're saying
is that Trump unleashed a corona virus
on purpose so that I didn't say that
why me that it no thanks whitter are
saying it I never liked the calling at
the Trump IRA I mean isn't everything
his fault though yeah it is so it's like
do you it's crazy as a if these people
acted like sane people I'd be ragging on
Trump like probably every day right but
because they've gone off the deep end
I'm like you make you forcing me to
defend the guy please right that's the
joke yeah there's a ton of people who
are like you know you know it's a thing
if if they just were honest hmm then
people would be like well you know
they're right about you know their when
they when they criticize the president
they're right about the things he's done
poorly instead they go out like this
late in MSNBC said that Trump was
talking about exterminating Latinos and
also an it's like yeah I'm not kidding
Oh seriously
literally what this woman said Trump was
talking about exterminating Latinos
that's what that is insane yeah when did
wrong with me would he have said that he
never did like now where's your proof to
back that up you can't make a claim like
that you've actually apologized later
she was like oh I didn't mean it like oh
sorry I was just I was just on a roll
that's how insane it is where it's like
dude I had some attention and I just
wanted to I needed some clickbait
everybody's lost their minds anyway
anyway directive 51 man yeah scary if it
does get really bad I mean I don't I
don't I don't expect to see this can you
pull up can you pull it up cuz we pulled
it up before it's really interesting the
National Security presidential directive
hold on I don't think it's gonna get
that bad I don't think so you know a lot
of people have minor cases they don't
even get pneumonia
it doesn't really here I got it
bedridden yeah I pulled it up to this
act let's let's pull this up hmm
national security national security and
Homeland Security presidential directive
national security president
that directive s NPD 51 is got big-name
executive directive 51 signed by George
W Bush on May 4 2007 is a presidential
directive establishing a comprehensive
policy on the federal government
structures and operations in the event
of a catastrophic emergency such an
emergency is defined as any incident
regardless of location that results in
extraordinary levels of mass casualties
damage or disruption severely affecting
the u.s. population infrastructure
environment economy or government
functions dare I say it based on net
we've already meet that met that
threshold the economy the economy's
taking a 30% hit or some like ridiculous
number already it's pretty crazy
actually and so now with this massive
disruption and around the cut on the
world no I don't think we would see its
use but the problem is it's it's odd
that we're you know it will it it will
there will come a time you ever see V
for Vendetta
yeah of course you know the plot is
right basically this we're saying in a
st. Mary's virus yeah and so they
basically enact this coughing yeah I'm
not saying that our government that I'm
saying that there will come a time and
you know these these federal government
people are just itching waiting for that
moment to be like give us that power yes
give us the excuse we're already seeing
this there's slip and stuff into bills
they're trying to get passed fast cuz
it's a crisis yep yeah I hate that you
want to see if you want to see you wanna
see you wanna see care scary you wanna
see scary check us out
California governor Gavin Newsom signs
executive order allowing the state to
take over hotels to house coronavirus
patients hours after calling for an end
to gatherings of 250 or more people that
is almost a violation of the third
amendment almost third amendment says
soldiers can't be quartered in your home
governor of California just said we're
taking over private businesses yeah to
house corona virus victims patients yeah
I mean does are they gonna pay like for
the hotel fees you know and I don't know
bottom dollar cost for each room like
how are they gonna do that
it doesn't really I don't think it says
actually here we go it's
120 room hotel in san carlos near san
francisco has already been earmarked to
house patients from the Grand Princess
ship under Newsom's new order the Desert
Sun reported this is where we need to go
next and make sure we fully implement
those procedures and protocols to slow
down the spread to get through a peak
and to get through the next few months
so we don't overwhelm our healthcare
delivery system asked why he did not go
further and issue a legally binding
binding ban on large gatherings Newsom
said that people appear to be doing the
right thing and following guidance well
I mean people don't to die or get sick
so they're you know they're hiding
anyway let's see so I don't know exactly
what the plan is are they gonna pay
these hotels but either way the for the
government to step up and say your
private property will now be taken by us
yeah is a scary measure now look I got I
get eminent domain exists right you know
that is yeah yeah so if they're gonna
build a highway or something they'll go
to your house and be like yo house is
now our house and we're gonna bulldoze
it and they pay you a fair market value
I guess mmm I don't know if they're
gonna be paying I would assume they'd
have to like compensate the hotel yeah
right but it's still scary when we get
to a point where we have this global
pandemic national emergency and the
government that's going like we taking
your property yep it's ours now and and
and here's what the area is fill it with
a bunch of sick people Thanks
when you give people this power they
don't give it up exactly they do not yep
they got a taste of it yeah yeah they
tasted human blood and now they're like
I ain't giving that out in the water
that's what I was saying about directive
51 mm-hmm I'm sure the ton of people
look at Michael Bloomberg could you
imagine if that guy became president uh
the guy dreaming thought he was he taxed
soda because he thought people are too
stupid it's like dude if I wanna drink a
soda I'm drinking a soda yeah and he was
like he actually there's a quote there's
a quote he's on where it's recorded
where he's like we need to tax the poor
for their own good because they buy
things that are bad for them so it's
good when we tax the poor that way we
can provide what they need amazing that
dude is the definition of like an
authoritarian communist and he wanted a
president could you imagine if he was no
be like what's wrong with directive 51
let's just take over and no one has to
worry about it anymore here shoot that
guy and that guy now why are they
yelling at me and you know what me and
that guy he looks sketchy shoot him too
like because the last I checked we're
all rich here there were in America and
this guy's waving a sign in my face
guards shoot him yep that dudes nuts
yeah he's scary dude I'm so glad he was
able to buy his way that's why America
it's why America is awesome because
everybody was like dude you know the
people who worked on his campaign
sabotaged it oh really yeah good for
them they were simple they're the real
heroes here
there were people being paid by well I
mean it's kind of messed up but you know
I'll say it they're the heroes no listen
listen
there were people working on his
campaign that were supposed to go out
and like canvass for him
okay I'm canvassed for Bernie Sanders
it's it's a thing like I'm saying like I
don't know because it is dirty but I
love it it couldn't have happened to a
nicer guy you know a man that dude is
awful and somebody made a real
interesting point when the story broke
about the about people you know
basically stabbing in the back and they
said perhaps this is a wake-up call to
you know the rich people that you can't
hire mercenaries to try and make your
campaign work because they have no
loyalty they don't care about you your
policies make no sense they don't they
don't want it mm-hmm
the people who need to work on your
campaign are people believe in your
campaign right and if they don't you got
mercenaries they're gonna walk out at
moment's notice
they're gonna go Kent you know the logo
canvass and someone will be like how
much is he paying you'll pay you more
like done Bloomberg got murked
that dude Bloomberg was was dumping
money on people that's how he was
getting him to work for him yeah
basically but anyway look man we've we
very quickly escalated from people
laughing about the corona virus being
nothing yeah to a national emergency
where the government of California is
taking over hotels I mean there's still
people out there saying like people are
freaking out for nothing like how dare
you the media should be like sued for
making it such a frowsy and it's like
but what this is a pandemic though it's
all over the globe I mean sure the death
rate doesn't seem high right now
because it's still spreading it's still
he caught it earlier yeah exactly so I'm
saying if we caught this late in the
death toll at 3 to 6 percent or whatever
was hundreds of thousands of people we'd
say why don't we catch this sooner
exactly now that we did everyone's like
ah who cares
saying I'm gonna go buy my TP I'll be
fine no but here's the thing I was think
about the ladies at 100k mm-hmm if
that's true then it is being overhyped
sure it's possible people are just
freaking out yeah yeah but I don't you
know I don't think that's the case mmm
China is an authoritarian nightmare of a
country okay that doesn't allow their
mia to freak out they were locking up
the people that were publishing
information about this that's true
and they still had a massive panic erupt
so yeah I think the media fuels the
frenzy mm-hmm but look man what is it
actions speak louder than words
yeah China can say whatever they want
the government's conservative look
whatever they want media can say
whatever they want but I'm watching what
the US military is doing I'm watching
what the Chinese government is doing I'm
watching what Italy should have done
yeah now the entire country is locked
down so maybe you know look there's like
I think I don't how many cases Italy has
now maybe it's up to like 20,000 or
something you know I think it's like
3,000 I think it's three thousand
hundred no Italy Italy no Italy was over
13,000 like yesterday oh really yeah the
other death rate was oh it wasn't here a
thousand oh maybe that's so this is what
I was saying early on when you look at
how China reacted I'm like I think
they're lying I think they're lying that
well you're right well you got do you
have the proof seventeen thousand six
hundred and sixty cases in Italy for
China we might not ever know how many
cases in Italy 17,000 17,000 now they're
there there are more cases of the flu
since flu scenes started back in October
mm-hmm the issue is I don't think I
think we're not gonna see the real
numbers
I mean we're polygons start seeing real
numbers now if Italy mm-hmm but what's
what's their total what their death rate
right now out of 1200 1200 what are you
kidding it's like that's new that's what
8% 7% that it was higher I thought it
was something like 3,000 oh if it was
3,000 yeah yeah yeah but if the death
rate is that high like around 6 7 %
maybe I think that's still pretty high I
think that's just because a lot of
Italy's population is so much older I'm
guessing and because they have so much
tourism I don't know I don't know man
it's kind of crazy to think about
because the the humans as a whole
there's a lot more old people now it
it's been like a thing that people have
been talking about like no kids aren't
having kids there's there's people are
living longer so the old people are
lasting longer and there's all this like
old people everywhere and it's like and
they're the ones getting hit there's all
the world everywhere I know but the
world's gonna look a lot different if
like half of the old people get taken
out by this but it's not it's like I
think it's people above 80 it's 14
percent mortality it's still pretty
crazy if they end up contracting it if
they get it yeah and so social
distancing is working here's here's the
thing Italy still did some stuff so I
think China's lying apparently there was
a report that the first case was
actually in November now it's going back
even further see I think Chinese
enterprising China got caught off guard
mm-hmm did nothing got slammed by this
panicked overreacted authoritarianism
you know that helped Italy under reacted
but still did reacted with some I think
this would have been substantially worse
if we literally did nothing or were
caught off guard by it yeah
so look actions speak louder than words
man when the Chinese government started
freaking out I was like I take that
seriously yeah I mean look they're goofy
people like the government not the
Chinese people I mean like the
government is it is a crazy Network
authoritarian nightmare you know yeah
they're nuts so maybe they're just out
of their minds
but I don't know you know if you see a
group of people screaming fire are you
gonna be like there's no fire here and
walk in the building or are you gonna be
like I'll take your word for it maybe I
shouldn't go in that building right
whether there's a fire or not yeah
either stay per stay so I'll put it this
way imagine you see a bunch of people
run out of a building a bunch of
firefighters show up screaming everyone
out run run for your lives and then the
guy walks up to insist don't worry
everything's fine there's no fire here
at all we've got everything under
control
and people are screaming in the
background they're knocking out windows
you're gonna be lying I don't believe
you yeah like it looks like you're
freaking out about a fire I'm gonna go
home yeah I'm not gonna go in this
building with fire in it so basically I
don't think we can have the dump the the
the Democratic convention how could we
yeah when is that in July yeah I think
so so this is how it works they do the
primaries right yeah then all the
delegates show up to this major
convention but it is a party dude it is
it is like
it is like an actual party like having
fun drinking party or yes very much
social gathering and there's a bunch of
companies that show up and it's like
South by it's like when you go to it's
gonna be a Milwaukee you're gonna see
all of these businesses are gonna Beach
their names are gonna be changed for the
DNC yeah CNN likes to do this thing
where they take over they'll they'll
rent a restaurant and change the name to
like CNN's kitchen or whatever I'm not
yeah for real home kitchen so they're
gonna they're gonna take these you know
Milwaukee over how can they do it if
they're shutting down III Google if
they're shutting down South by Southwest
well it's a few months away from now but
right I mean yeah but I mean a lot of
these other conferences so so well I
guess we'll see what happens but even if
it's not as bad as we think it is the
panic is gonna be bad the panic is bad
already yep
people are freaking out thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you